well ladies and gentlemen we had
primaries last night and as expected
Wyoming Republican congresswoman Liz
Cheney has been absolutely brutally
defeated in her Republican primary did
she abandon Republican Orthodoxy was she
pro-choice or against lowering taxes on
the rich or any policy it no it wasn't
anything like that she simply said that
Donald Trump really did lose the
election in 2020 and for that the Maga
people determined that she had to be
punished and she will now be replaced on
the November final general election
ballot by Harriet Hageman an individual
whose political views are essentially
identical to Liz Cheney's with the
exception that Harriet Hageman has
parroted the claim that Joe Biden didn't
really win in November of 2020 and that
apparently was a more mortal sin let's
talk about last night's primaries as the
Associated Press reports Trump fo Cheney
loses Wyoming GOP Primary
Ponders 2024 bid I don't even care about
the 2024 thing for now she was on with
Savannah Guthrie this morning and sort
of said I'm going to think about 24.
there's no real need to talk about that
right now a lot of things will happen
between now and then uh Liz Cheney
Trump's fiercest Republican adversary
writes the AP in in Congress soundly
lost a Republican primary failing but
Falling to a rival backed by the former
president in a route that reinforced his
grip on the party's base
the third term congresswoman and her
allies entered Tuesday downbeat about
her prospects and listen she lost I mean
I don't even really know what else we
need to pull from this she lost and she
lost very very significantly
and the reason that she became a target
of the Maga people and of Donald Trump
is that she insisted
Trump didn't win in 2020. Trump really
genuinely lost she's still a Republican
she still voted the way Trump uh uh
wanted 93 percent of the time when she
was in Congress and Trump was president
but she says no Trump genuinely did lose
and in her concession speech sort of her
her speech that she gave
she says I easily won last time I could
have won again I just would have had to
lie and say that Trump won and I wasn't
willing to do that let's listen to what
she had to say last night
two years ago I won this primary with 73
percent of the votes true I could easily
have done the same again the path was
clear
but it would have required that I go
along with President Trump's lie about
the 2020 election right it would have
required that I enable his ongoing
efforts to unravel our democratic system
and attack the foundations of our
Republic
that was a path I could not and would
not take
the Lincoln project commented on Liz
Cheney's primary loss that's a group
made of sort of non-trump Republicans
for the most part and they said tonight
marks the end of the Republican party
what remains shares the name of the
Republican party but it is in fact an
authoritarian nationalist cult dedicated
only to Donald Trump so there's really
two sides to this is it wacky and is it
disturbing that this is what the
Republican party has become of course it
is of course it's wacky and disturbing
the goal of the Maga people is to purge
the Republican Party of the critics of
Donald Trump even something as benign is
saying the results were the Real Results
Joe Biden did win Donald Trump did lose
you've got Adam kinzinger retiring Liz
Cheney lost her primary some of the
other Republicans who did vote to
convict Trump on that second impeachment
trial are either retiring or lost
primaries so it is absolutely crazy that
that's the situation at the same time
it's important to remind you that
Liz Cheney mostly voted with Trump and
she's being replaced by someone who will
mostly vote in the way that Trump would
want will vote with the Republican party
whatever that Harriet Hageman will vote
the same way as Liz Cheney on just about
every issue the only difference is
Hageman is willing to repeat the big lie
whereas Liz Cheney was not so it's also
disturbing because on policy there is
essentially no difference between
Hageman and Cheney they're both against
abortion they're both for you know lower
taxes for the rich whatever the
difference is actually just one about
this issue where it's about an election
that was almost two years ago so that's
also sad now these results could
potentially backfire and I'll mention
the way in which that could happen
Wyoming's total population is 580 000.
no I'm not saying 580 000 people voted
yesterday I'm not saying there's 580 000
Republicans the total population of
Wyoming is five hundred and eighty
thousand tiny electorate much more
subject to having a primary manipulated
by out-of-state money and Trump and the
Maga people these results could send a
signal to the more reasonable
Republicans in other parts of the
country to the extent that they they
exist and to a little extent they do
that the Republican party is now the
Maga party and many Republicans aren't
at all in favor of this being a Maga
party if you're Mitt Romney for example
it is at this point thanks to the
Democratic party that was we still even
have some semblance of democracy in the
United States but if you're Romney you
should understand that your own party
will come for you at least potentially
and we have to see what the impact is of
that on to the extent that they exist
the more moderate and reasonable
Republicans now a couple other elections
from last night Lisa murkowski also was
challenged by uh a pro-trump republican
in Alaska in the Senate
she won enough votes to advance to the
general election in November in that
Senate race and Sarah Palin although she
did not get the most votes in her Alaska
Congressional primary yesterday
um she also will advance uh to November
so that's what's going on and we're
going to have these are it's an open
house seat for Sarah Palin and we will
see in November what happens with that
but
um very disturbing results that's for
sure let's now go and talk about the
Senate I have to tell you that the
Senate is not looking so bad now we'll
look at the general Senate numbers in a
moment but there are three prominent
Republicans who as of right now are
losing their Senate races let's talk
about them one by one first and foremost
Val demings member of Congress
Democratic member of congress former
police officer she has decided to
challenge Marco Rubio the incumbent
Republican Florida senator for his seat
she's currently winning by four
this could go in any direction between
now and November but we're only two and
a half months away and to be such a long
time incumbent Senator as Marco Rubio
sort of a celebrity Senator to the
extent that he ran for president and
he's more well known than you know uh
pick whoever Ben sass I don't know uh
Senators whose names I don't even know
um and so the fact that he is down for
is not insignificant as the hill reports
Val demings leads Rubio by four
according to a poll released Tuesday the
poll is from University of North
Florida's public opinion research lab it
shows Deming deming's at 48 Rubio at 44.
seven percent saying they would choose
someone else now much of that seven
percent will ultimately vote for demings
or Rubio so that is very very
interesting now a couple of other races
that are interesting there is the Mehmet
Oz versus John fetterman race in
Pennsylvania in the Senate there as I've
told you before this is a race that
could decide whether Democrats or
Republicans control the Senate after the
November 11 election this is not a race
that is looking very good for Mehmet Oz
despite all of his personal wealth and
uh cringe ads and everything the latest
Fox News poll has it at fetterman plus
11 the Fabrizio anzaloni poll has it at
fetterman plus six USA Today fetterman
plus nine those aren't particularly new
polls but on average right now according
to Real Clear Politics fetterman leading
Oz by on average 8.7 points that's good
news for Democrats as well
and then lastly in Georgia and this is a
really scary one because it is way way
too close in Georgia incumbent
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock is
trying to beat off a challenge from
Herschel Walker Herschel Walker is the
Republican nominee who cannot speak who
cannot put together a coherent sentence
and yet somehow look at these numbers
Warnock yes he's leading but he is
leading by only an average of 4.4 points
in that race
Walker cannot think and cannot speak he
understands not a single political issue
and he's almost within the margin of
error
that is endlessly endlessly horrifying
about what it says about the United
States and its electorate now overall
how are things looking for the fall if
we look at the 538 forecast in the
Senate Democrats are now up to a 61
percent chance of of holding the Senate
this is a number that started at roughly
50 50 months ago and over time the
scenarios have shifted more and more and
more in favor of Democrats holding the
Senate now 61 in 100 doesn't mean
Democrats are likely to have 61 seats
not even close in fact as you can see on
this graphic the most likely scenarios
are either another 50 50 split with
Kamala Harris being the tie-breaking
vote meaning Democrats control Democrats
having 51 seats or 52 seats those are
the most likely scenarios but a 61
chance of holding the Senate when really
Republicans should be taking it
historically speaking
um is not altogether terrible and then
over in the House of Representatives the
odds have improved just marginally for
Democrats but still roughly a four to
one Edge for Republicans a week or two
ago I told you that Democrats had only a
20 chance of winning the house that is
just barely inched up flaccidly to 22
from 20 so in in all likelihood
Democrats will lose the house but if
indeed they maintain the Senate they
will at least be able to prevent
Republicans from doing any serious
damage now also in terms of the Senate
North Carolina is in play a Florida uh
um a rather 538 has North Carolina
looking similar to Florida in terms of
the odds that a Democrat takes that seat
and we are going to continue following
all of these numbers but the most likely
scenario the closer we get the more we
can kind of narrow our prediction
the most uh likely outcome right now is
Democrats hold the Senate lose the house
and we have just vile obstruction for
the next two years and nothing gets done
and then Republicans use their own
obstruction to try to justify voting for
a republican for president in 2024
because Joe Biden didn't get anything
done for those last two years thanks to
them of course so that's where we are
right now I look forward to taking your
questions about the 2022 midterms during
our upcoming member only
viewer Town Hall we do many wide open
full audience viewer Town Halls we are
holding an exclusive event on Wednesday
August 31 at 6 PM eastern time where
members will be able to call in and chat
with me we will stream the event for
everybody but only members will
participate if you would like to
participate simply sign up at
joinpakman.com
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
well another day and another major
legislative accomplishment for Joe Biden
whose presidency in the last two months
as I told you about yesterday and the
day before has really turned itself
around the inflation reduction act has
now been signed into law by President
Joe Biden this bill you might recall
barely passed the U.S Senate 5150 but
sir how could it add up to 101 votes
well it was 50 50 with Kamala Harris as
vice president is the president of the
Senate casting the tie-breaking vote 51
that was on August 7th there were no
Republican votes we also saw the bill on
Friday past the U.S house not
particularly widely by a 220 to 207
margin and Joe Biden has now signed the
bill into law and it is indeed major
major legislation let's take a look at
what this bill does it is a more than
430 billion dollar package expected to
reduce the deficit by over 300 billion
dollars over 10 years
it's expected to raise
737 billion dollars in Revenue over 10
years and it includes 369 billion in
investment money for climate and energy
policy 64 billion dollars to extend the
Affordable Care Act policy that reduces
health insurance costs so to be more
honest sometimes what it what we can
maybe more accurately say is it slows
down the rate of increase for health
insurance costs it includes importantly
notably a 15 corporate minimum tax for
companies earning over a billion dollars
a year this is a subject of much
discussion which is for individuals
there has been an alternative minimum
tax for a long time and the concept of
an alternative minimum taxes you make a
million dollars personally you can use
deductions and losses and all these
different things to offset the full
million in taxes and you end up owing
zero in order to prevent that something
called the Alternative Minimum Tax was
established which says that for a
certain level of income no matter how
many deductions and losses you have to
offset taxable income you have to pay
some minimum tax we never ever had that
for corporations this bill puts that in
place at a 15 percent rate it also puts
in place a one percent tax on stock
BuyBacks done by large corporations this
was something that was a big deal during
the pandemic you may recall
uh when the Donald Trump uh coronavirus
stimuli packages were um enacted many
corporations from the corporate side of
it used the money they got to just buy
back their own stock raising its price
so this bill puts in place a one percent
tax when you do stock BuyBacks it will
reduce drug prices for Medicare
recipients uh it will it expects to
collect an additional 124 billion
dollars from increased IRS enforcement
so there's money in the bill
controversially so for many to hire more
IRS agents the belief is that those
additional agents are going to find tax
cheats and recover 124 billion
additional dollars it includes tax
credits to incentivize electric cars and
electric HVAC systems as well as other
forms of cleaner technology that's great
and it is expected to cut pollution by
around 40 percent below the 2005 level
by 2030. and it also puts in place a two
thousand dollar a year out of pocket cap
for Medicare recipients now a few
thoughts on this number one is this a
major legislative accomplishment for Joe
Biden yes it is will people vote based
on this in November uh it's not totally
clear
um we'll see what polling suggests over
the next probably two to three weeks
regardless of your political persuasion
there are things in this that are
beneficial to most of the Americans uh
in the country
for example the two thousand dollar
out-of-pocket cap for Medicare
recipients Medicare recipients are both
Democrats and Republicans in fact we
it's a more conservative group we know
that every older cohort is slightly more
conservative in the United States right
now uh less pollution is everybody
benefits from less pollution even if
you're against
green energy or whatever
um all there are things in here from
which everyone benefits regardless of
political persuasion now I want to
take a sort of political overview of the
Biden Administration generally My
Philosophy is generally speaking to
judge Presidents by what they do more
than by what they don't do now there are
exceptions to that for example Donald
Trump failed to do many things in terms
of his coveted response that is an area
where you have an acute situation and it
seems logical to say look all these
other world leaders did these things
Trump failed to do that that was an
acute thing but there are people who
wrote to me over the last 12 to 24 hours
about the inflation reduction act saying
David this is not good for Biden what we
need to be focusing on with Biden is he
hasn't decriminalized marijuana
he hasn't forgiven all student debt by
the way Joe Biden did forgive a bunch
more student debt overnight and we'll
talk about that on the bonus show Joe
Biden did not do XYZ right
um Trump also didn't decriminalize
marijuana Obama didn't decriminalize
marijuana it seems to me if we're trying
to evaluate a president's performance
none of them decriminalize marijuana and
it sort of zeros out I want cannabis
decriminalized to be clear but it seems
weird to me to react to what is clearly
a major legislative accomplishment and
to say well Biden hasn't done this other
thing I tend to judge Presidents by the
things that they do and this is a very
good thing this should be screened from
the rooftops on media social media Etc
by democrats and remind people you all
benefit from things in this bill even
though every Republican in the Senate
voted against it so are there things Joe
Biden uh has not done that I would like
to see him do absolutely have I been
critical of Joe Biden's lack of
accomplishments I have 100 percent but
this is an accomplishment the jobs
numbers are good the economy is looking
very good inflation's coming down The
Pact act has been signed for people that
think this type of thing is good he is
gone and uh he approved the strike that
killed Al-Qaeda terrorist I'm an
al-zawahiri many of you have concerns
about due process I share those concerns
these are the things he has done
and it makes absolute and perfect sense
for to give him credit for those and
then compare to the alternative when it
comes time if he runs for reelection
what would this other person who is
eventually going to be the Republican
nominee what would they have done in
this situation they wouldn't have passed
the inflation reduction act they likely
would not have passed the pact act they
wouldn't have done a lot of the things
Joe Biden did that are good and then we
evaluate well is it worthy of reelection
that's a question for them down down the
road we don't even know if Biden is
running Rudy Giuliani is now reportedly
panicking and his priority is to die a
free man to die a free man that doesn't
sound like things are going particularly
well Rudy Giuliani is now being forced
to appear before a Georgia grand jury
investigating the Trump and Associates
attempts to overturn the results in
November of 2020 results in which Joe
Biden won Georgia let me say that in a
very clear Away Joe Biden won Georgia so
Joe Biden should have gotten and did get
the electoral votes from Georgia however
Donald Trump and Rudy Giuliani and Jenna
Ellis and a whole bunch of different
people Lindsey Graham were to different
degrees and in different ways lobbying
for Trump to get those electoral votes
that would have been wrong Rudy Giuliani
now has to appear before a grand jury he
tried having his lawyers say he can't
travel
Rudy travels all the time didn't make
any sense judge didn't buy it he is
arguably going to try to say that
everything he did was as the lawyer for
Trump and therefore it's protected by
attorney-client privilege but it doesn't
seem like it's necessarily going to work
but we now are being told that Rudy is
concerned that he may not die a free man
that is very very serious well I can't I
want to start with you sure as someone
who worked for rude Giuliani John did
also but you were really as press
secretary the Target now of this
investigation that's a big deal this is
a big deal and he's trying to create a
smoke screen and delay as long as
possible listen Rudy flew too close to
the Sun you got too close to Trump he
got burned
um he knows how do he flew too close to
the Sun on the wings of Maga trumpism
and you can't do that and avoid getting
burned forever she works he knows how
the FBI Works he knows these are
meticulous investigations I I know this
is not a popular position with the media
but I think we should take a wait and
see
um uh that the affidavit shouldn't be
released I'm doubling back to the
earlier conversation
um I know he's I know he's nervous uh he
could have flown uh to Georgia you know
he flies all over the world yep so
that's just a typical uh tactic to try
to postpone the inevitable why do you
think he's nervous about this Georgia
investigations because he know he knows
the truth he knows he lied to
legislators he knows that he concocted
this false electorate scheme
um you know he knows he lied for his
client and he knows we all know it's
it's clear what's his next move
at delay delay delay take the can down
the road I think you know at this point
in his life his goal is to
die a free man can you imagine
look at how quickly Rudy who is mayor
911 beloved by everybody even many
Democrats and all of a sudden it's am I
gonna die in prison or am I going to die
a free man
pretty Stark John that is Stark and look
it highlights I think the tragedy of his
trajectory
um but it's a self-inflicted tragedy
true you know the deal is that Rudy was
as Ken knows really one of the most
respected legal minds of his generation
I remember him telling me many times
that you know the law is about a search
for the truth
and that is not what he is is is
pursuing right now trying to evade the
truth um because he's afraid of what
will will come up now he is saying look
I was acting in the capacity as lawyer
and whether president ex-president
ultimately throws him under the bus is
yet to be seen but I will also say the
Rudy Giuliani is someone who said many
times on tape from the Blue Room at City
Hall that you know you respect the
sanctity of a grand jury they know more
than we do and so to push back against
that as aggressively as he has and to
throw around terms like fascist State uh
is beneath the man he was and The
credibility he once had to be clear
Bernard about the luck he's going to
have pursuing this yes delay but success
probably not I mean the judge has said
hey collectors you have to comply yep
Congressman Jody Heist you have to
comply Senator Graham you have to show
up exactly so where Rudy Giuliani you
can run but you can't hide your time is
up you have now graduated to being a
Target and now it's your time to appear
before this grand jury if you complete
the fifth yes he can decide oh
attorney-client privilege but then you
have the crime fraud exception but
there's so much that can go on so bottom
line here it's sort of a sad tale about
Rudy Giuliani in a sense I mean on a
personal level it is sad you've got a
guy who's uh I think 76 77 years old
something like that
um he did have even though he was not my
political preference he did have a good
career Prosecuting the mafia followed by
being mayor of 9 11 and after nine uh
the mayor of 9 11. the mayor of New York
City during 9 11 the mayor of 9 11
sounds really bad the mayor of New York
City during 9 11 widely seen as was
George W bush as participating in sort
of bringing the nation together and
handling it well and then it started to
get a little weird where Rudy would not
stop talking about 9 11 no matter what
the question was for years after he was
mayor and then he attached his wagon to
Trump's horse and that is a hell of a
horse to attach Your Wagon to and it is
self-inflicted so it can be both sad and
also correct that Rudy now has to deal
with this he did things that he knew
were were the wrong things to do in
terms of telling lies Etc and he's going
to have to face the consequences these
clips are all on our Instagram which you
can find by searching Instagram for
David packman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with attorney
Mark Bankston who's a partner at Farah
and ball and is lead counsel in several
defamation lawsuits against Alex Jones
and Infowars some people may recognize
him from dozens and dozens and dozens of
viral YouTube videos that uh we all
looked at extensively Mark great having
you on today hey thanks for having me
David So how how did you end up uh doing
these cases and and representing a
variety of different plaintiffs here
here in defamation against Alex Jones
and Infowars
I'm glad you asked me that because you
know a lot of people just start and end
with these Sandy Hook cases but the
first lawsuit I actually brought against
Jones was for a young man in the Boston
area who was inexplicably accused of
being the Parkland shooter in the 2018
shootings in Florida and at that time I
I was in touch with this young man and
he had never even been to Florida it
turned out that he was accused on 4chan
of being the Parkland shooter and it was
because he was wearing a
communist-themed t-shirt he had the the
comedy t-shirt that's the Communist
Leaders with lampshades on their heads
drinking from Solo cups so visual pun on
Communist Party well Infowars just ran
with that because they were so excited
that they could claim that the shooter
was a communist and they took this kid's
picture who was being teased on 4chan
and put it all over the world he reached
out to me and we brought suit back in
March of 2018 and when we did that and
that made national headlines uh several
Sandy Hook parents picked up the phone
and they said you know we've been trying
to get somebody to bring these suits for
us somebody who take on Alex Jones
people were saying it's too hard or it's
too big of a fight we need to find a
lawyer who would do it and I said you
found one so in in general with these
types of cases what is it you have to
prove to actually be able to Prevail in
a case because it's not just that a
statement was pejorative but there are
specific requirements that have to be
met and and do they vary state by state
they do a little bit right our common
law of defamation is as old as the Magna
Carta but every state has a little bit
different rules but it basically boils
down to this you have to prove three
things you have to prove that they
published a false statement
and that the second thing you have to
prove is that it was of or concerning a
specific individual and the third thing
you have to prove is that that false
statement caused them some sort of
Damages and it's it's interesting
because you know these cases actually
ended up having default judgments on the
liability but it was never really
something we needed uh it was sort of uh
you know in a lot of cases that would be
an enormous Victory but in this case it
was never going to be difficult to prove
that Alex Jones published false
statements about these people that
caused them damages this case was always
about how much Alex Jones needed to be
punished when it comes to the Judgment
that you obtained which made number of
headlines at close to 50 million dollars
there are State limits on what can
actually be collected is that correct I
mean what what is it looking like will
actually be the liability for Jones of
the 49 million dollars
it's interesting because everyone's
talking about this right now and most of
the people who are talking about it are
not familiar with Texas law there is a
punitive damage cap statute that was
passed by the legislature however it
does not apply under all factual
situations there are large amounts of
exceptions to it okay um we are going to
be moving for the entry of judgment
sometime later this week and we'll have
a hearing with the court soon and we're
very confident that those caps aren't
going to apply there are several reasons
why under this case and those will be
discussed at the hearing coming up but
we believe it will be the full 50
million dollar verdict the defendants
are going to try to argue a cap Applause
which basically limits us to 750 000 in
additional damages per claim per
defendant okay there are three claims
with two defendants each that would be a
practical cap of 4.5 million at the end
of the day with costs and the interest
it would be a total verdict of about 10.
but we actually do believe that we're
going to have uh going to be able to get
around those caps with the exceptions
and that will be collecting the entire
50 million dollar verdict what's your
best assessment of the real financial
situation at this point of Alex Jones
and Infowars because as many of in my
audience know there has been an
assertion of bankruptcy and as the judge
in your case astutely pointed out just
because you claim bankruptcy doesn't
mean you actually are bankrupt there are
some statements I've seen from Jones
basically copying to the reality that
it's a strategic move specifically to
try to limit the amount that can
actually be collected from him in this
and maybe in other cases what's your
best assessment of his financial
position it's a real difficult question
to answer you know we had some very
limited and contradictory evidence on
that at trial and we know that his
revenues are enormous but what's harder
to understand is what's going on behind
the scenes right we have now started to
encounter some very disturbing evidence
that is showing Mr Jones has been
pulling millions and millions out of his
business after these default judgments
in fact in this just this last year
Jones used his business like a cash
machine to the tune of 60 million
dollars that he removed from the company
we really don't know what is all there
but we know there is a very significant
amount of money uh it we feel though
that by the end of all these lawsuits
you know there's there's eight more
plaintiffs up in Connecticut I have two
more I'm taking to trial on a Sandy Hook
case plus another case of that Parkland
case we're we're pretty sure these
verdicts are going to wipe them out but
actually chasing him down for that money
and the collections process may become
as interesting as the lawsuits
themselves in a case like this if
someone just sort of like doesn't wire
the money for lack of a better term What
mechanisms are there like you know in
evictions eventually the men with guns
show up and kick you out sort of thing
like what ultimately happens in a case
like this well if it was a normal case
and we were collecting outside of
bankruptcy we have lots of tools at our
disposal we can do a writ of execution
that essentially sends the sheriff over
to Infowars and starts seizing computers
and cameras those are the tools that you
would normally have at your disposal but
this bankruptcy proceeding is going to
be very interesting because now you're
going to have a federal bankruptcy judge
and a U.S trustee who are overseeing the
financial scrutiny of Infowars that
process itself is going to be very very
dangerous for Mr Jones and and we are I
think by the end of all of that we're
not going to need to resort to sending
sheriffs out we think the the federal
enforcement process is in the bankruptcy
court are going to divide up the Joneses
Empire when you say pulling money out of
businesses is that and kind of running
it through various llc's is it all
domestic do you have evidence that money
is being offshored no you're thinking
way too high level you're thinking Mike
that they're sophisticated to financial
operators yeah I'm literally talking
about just money straight drawn out of
the company like it's an ATM and put
into Jones's hands cash 60 million cash
taken out of the company not routed
through another LLC not anything like
this but but denoted on the balance
sheets purely as a member draw and Jones
is the only member of free speech
systems so he really is just using the
company like a piggy bank where exactly
that money went and what happened to it
is some questions that are going to be
answered in the coming months and and
again you're talking about physical cash
I don't you know that's harder to say
that really is I I sort of don't suspect
that there was giant briefcases full of
60 million right like I have to think
that there was some sort of electronic
transfer into certain accounts what we
don't know yet is what accounts those
went to we know since that it was member
draws that that money was paid out to
Alex Jones but where it went from there
is very difficult to know yet
so there were all sorts of just things
that to me were unprecedented I had
never seen before like for example that
there was a running commentary on
Infowars about the case as it was going
on and then there were exhibits brought
in from during the trial which were
about the judge about the jury Etc
how did you even manage this was it just
like even during the trial you needed a
team watching every minute that was
produced and broadcast
absolutely and I had one luckily uh one
stepped up is you know we're in court
all day we can't do that right
um You may be familiar with Dan Friesen
of the podcast knowledge fight who I
would consider maybe the world's
foremost authority on Alex Jones he had
actually joined on as a Consulting
expert pro bono very early in the case
and he in the knowledge fight team
during the days of trial would keep
track of what was said clip out the
parts that we were interested in and
provide them to us those became exhibits
in the courtroom and it's it's really
funny when you think about it that those
those things almost get lost in the
details there's so many people talking
about for instance Jones Ambush on the
stand about his text messages and it
almost gets forgotten that there were
videos of them accusing the judge of
pedophilia right and saying that the
trial was rigged and that the jurors are
a bunch of blue-collar yokels you don't
understand what's going on if that had
happened in any other trial that would
be the top story that would be the
headline but there's so much that went
on in this trial that almost gets lost
in the details so the the text message
thing for people who may not have seen
or don't remember there was this
incredible situation where for days uh
you were sort of setting up a number of
different denials about Alex Jones
having had text messages specifically
related to Sandy Hook on his phone then
it turned out you actually had a digital
copy of what was on his phone because
his attorney accidentally as far as we
know sent that digital copy to you and
this became a huge flash point in the
trial and corporate media covered it Etc
first question at any point did you
think that maybe it was a deliberate
accident in order to either try to argue
for a mistrial or in some way manipulate
the situation in their favor I knew that
it wasn't deliberate in the sense that
it was a strategy in Mr Jones's favor I
knew that
um I will admit that very briefly I had
the same sort of wild ideas in my head
that Roger Stone has been spreading the
last few days of is is Andino Renault an
agent of the deep state for you know
used to work at the doj for Eric Holder
is he screwing over Alex Jones some way
in a couple of seconds though you
realize no that's that's wild wild
thinking the the reality of it is is you
had an attorney who was not used to
doing civil law decided he was going to
take some money to come in and represent
Alex Jones purely for the fame and
attention and he was not able to protect
his clients data like he needed to those
were not in my eyes intentional moves or
strategic moves they were actually very
serious breaches of his duties to his
client
um and and that just sometimes happened
when somebody's in over their head like
this there was a large uh you know an
hour or so at least that I remember
during which a number of requests were
made by Alex Jones Council of the judge
when it came to that digital copy and I
don't I didn't fully grasp the the sort
of fundamentals of what it was that they
were asking for on the basis that those
doc that that record was accidentally
sent to you what was it that they were
asking for and why was it that it was
not uh granted by the judge well it's
funny that you say you were having
trouble figuring out what they were
asking for because so were we okay we uh
they were asking for things that made no
sense in the context uh they wanted the
judge to just do a blanket ceiling order
over the entire documents but they had
no basis to just suddenly seal 2.3
gigabytes of information that's not how
these rules work okay they actually had
10 days from the time of disclosure to
specifically identify any documents that
either had a legal privilege like they
were between attorney they were husband
and wife something like that or that
were confidential because they were a
trade secret or sensitive in some way
and they just didn't do it
um and so when they came into the court
having violated all the rules to do that
and then we're essentially saying that
that that my side had somehow acted in
properly that was quickly dismissed by
the judge she actually did give them the
opportunity to in a day designate
anything as confidential which means
that I could still have it I just
couldn't share it outside the courtroom
they actually didn't do any of that
um so the second day of those hearings
the last day of trial basically the
judge declared them free and clear
they're in my hands now I'm going to uh
become some bad news for Mr Jones could
Mr Jones argue against the ultimate
judgment on the basis that his counsel
inadequately represented him
interestingly no you have that option in
criminal law okay if your criminal
defense lawyer provides you an effective
assistance that is a basis for appeal
but in civil law it is not and I think
it's a good rule because I think it'd be
rare that a criminal lawyer would
intentionally throw a case because this
client's going to end up in jail but in
a civil case it could it's more
foreseeable and so we don't let
ineffective assistance be the basis of
of their defense particularly in
criminal law a lot of people have
appointed counsel they can't choose who
their lawyer is Mr Jones got to choose
this lawyer you revealed on The Young
Turks last week when speaking to our
friend Anna kasparian that in that
digital copy there was a nude photo of
Alex Jones wife sent to Roger Stone and
since then Erica Wolfe Jones came out
and said that it was non-consensual it's
not clear to me whether she means that
the picture was taken non-consensually
or she knew about the picture but it was
not consensual to send it to Roger Stone
what on Earth is going on when it comes
to this this is almost like a side story
but raising a ton of different questions
about the relationship between Jones and
stone and just bizarre things that you
often just never even see become part of
a trial is there anything else on that
that you've since found out
I mean the only thing that I can say
that I can help clarify the record on
that is because Jones is actually what I
found was interesting is after I
discussed that Jones actually showed the
picture on his show
um which I thought was strange
um but what I can tell you is from the
nature of the
picture it was definitely constantially
taken right it wasn't it wasn't
something that he was creep shotting her
or something like that uh the the
non-consent issue comes that it was sent
apropos of nothing to Roger Stone and in
what seems to be a bid for his attention
that was totally ignored by Stone uh
just a random picture that was sent in
some other messages trying to get his
attention as terms of what's going on in
the future with those kinds of issues
because I brought that to the fore
because it it does look like a crime and
that's not that's not an okay thing to
do oh is that right so it would be that
it's even if the picture was taken
consensually to disseminate it is
potentially Criminal correct and I mean
there's some there's some caveats to
that in Texas there has to be basically
an intent to harm or embarrass or
something like that but sending your
wife's picture to Roger Stone
non-consensually pretty much meets that
that definition
um and so you know I'm glad that Miss
wolf Jones knows about that now
um and and there's a lot of other things
in those text messages that will likely
come out in due course which raise other
troubling issues in Mr Jones's life um
and so as that process goes forward uh
there may very well be more Revelations
about what's going on there uh do you
think I might have a defamation case
against Alex Jones he did call me a
predator about six months ago because I
have a paid membership program on my
show where people can pay and get access
to an extra 20-minute show a day I can't
really say that I was damaged by it in
fact it was probably the best possible
thing that's ever happened to be honest
I probably don't have a case right no I
would figure it out for a couple reasons
one is you're very much a public figure
now you know uh you were a guy involved
in the middle of the discourse and in
this country we let you be pretty
reckless right up to the edge about
public figures right different than the
Sandy Hook parents right
um but it's also funny that I just find
it ironic that here you are talking
about a promotion program you're doing
on your your show for more content right
and here's a guy who's Hawking you know
super male Vitality rainforest and he's
calling you a predator that's that's
really funny to me I I think it's also
funny you bring this up because somebody
was asking me today to explain said can
you who's David Pac-Man what's the show
about obviously an older person who is
not watching their news on the internet
sure and the best thing I could come up
with was imagine if Alex Jones wasn't
bad imagine if somebody was doing news
and commentary on the internet in an
independent way that wasn't just a grift
to try to sell you pills that turn you
read right like what if you had that and
and I'm you know that's one of the
reasons I went on TNT tyt one of the
reasons I was really happy to come here
yeah is because the solution sure isn't
good through the corporate media it's
through shows like this and by people
who are taking it seriously being
responsible well I appreciate that um
last thing I want to ask you about the
the last time I was in the same room
with Alex Jones was years ago at a radio
uh conference called the New Media
seminar which I don't even know if it
exists anymore and at the time my
Impressions were he's playing a
character my Impressions were that he
got off the stage after giving a sort of
animated but still kind of normal speech
and he said something like you know I
could have really freaked him out if I
wanted to and it seemed that he sort of
understood that the on-air Persona was
not at all his sort of real life in the
last two years from everything I've seen
and read in interactions with Jones out
in public that people have it's
increasingly seeming like the the
Infowars Alex Jones is the the real guy
in your experience having been in the
room with him for as long as you were is
it is it a character or is that the real
Alex Jones
you know that is a question I have
struggled with since the beginning and
at the start I thought I knew the answer
and I think that has changed over time
for me it's you you see at first I was
positive and I still remain very
positive that most of the things he said
for instance about Sandy Hook he never
believed he never believed there were
pictures of the children still alive he
never really believed the school was
shut down and stalked and was a fake
school I don't think he believed any of
that and so there was a time that I
really believed that he was a
sophisticated operator completely
detached from the things he was saying
but as we went through this whole
process I'd opposed him several times as
we went through trial I also realized
there is no off switch for Jones and
there is a something about spending
every day wrapped in your own BS that it
starts to actually affect you and there
is a mindset Jones I think you're right
when you say that he is conscious of how
his words appear to people he and he is
any and he wants to try to control that
but here we just saw him in this trial
totally unable to turn off the Freak
Flag just for 10 minutes in front of
that jury and it really shows that
there's there's two sides of Jones there
is a very very conscious manipulator
side to Jones and then there is a side
where he is not really in control of
himself yeah those two parts of himself
are at War and right now the part of him
that's out of control has been winning
handily for the last couple years yeah
out of control is uh quite quite an
understatement Mark Bankston partner at
pharah and ball and Lead counsel in a
number of defamation lawsuits against
Alex Jones and Infowars Mark really a
pleasure having you on today
hey really pleasure being here if you
ever have legal questions and want to
talk about some more stuff please have
me back
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
early last week or middle of last week I
came to you and I told you that Donald
Trump is now conducting a frantic and
frenetic search for criminal defense
attorneys why well he and others
increasingly believe that an indictment
criminally is at least a real
possibility real enough that he truly
needs to have criminal defense attorneys
ready to go it appears as though that
search is not going particularly well
and there's a few reasons for that as
the Washington Post reports Trump is
rushing to hire seasoned lawyers but he
keeps hearing no the for this is just an
unbelievable line the former president's
current legal team includes a Florida
insurance lawyer who's never had a
federal case a past general counsel for
a parking garage company and a former
host at far right won America news
can you imagine that as the former
president of the United States this is
the struggle that you are experiencing
he is rushing to assemble a team of
respected lawyers but the answer they
keep hearing is no
the struggle to find expert legal advice
puts Trump in a bind as he faces
potential criminal exposure from a
records dispute with the National
Archives everyone is saying no said a
prominent Republican lawyer who like
some others spoke on the condition of
anonymity to discuss confidential
conversations
long time confidence of and advisors of
Trump have grown worried about Trump's
current stable of lawyers noting most of
them have little to no experience in
cases of this type according to two
people familiar with the discussions
Taylor budowitz a trump spokesman
defended the quality of the former
president's legal team in a statement
Tuesday
um but it is not particularly good John
sale a prominent Florida defense
attorney who worked on the Watergate
prosecution team said he turned down
representing Trump because he didn't
have enough time
you have to evaluate whether you want to
take it it's not like a DUI it's
representing the former president of the
U.S and maybe the next one in what's one
of the highest visibility cases ever so
normally as the article says it's
prestigious and and creates a lot of
publicity when you represent a former
president
but this is a very different situation
and we have to be able to kind of just
say we we know what's going on here
right I mean big picture look at what
has happened to the people that defend
Trump you end up disbarred you end up
subpoenaed you end up indicted you're
left with an unpaid legal bill at the
end of the day you become ridiculed I
mean Sydney Powell I am sure and Sydney
Powell is probably wackier than the
people that they've been trying to get
to represent Trump Sydney Powell I'm
sure believed this is my ticket to Legal
Fame this is my ticket to Legal riches
I'm going to get so many clients and
it'll be so prestigious and the pr will
be great and then she starts going
around with Rudy Giuliani and doing
these completely humiliating
um appearances everywhere and she ends
up disbarred and I think it was New York
and DC I don't remember off the top of
my head it doesn't go particularly well
look at what happened to Michael Cohen
look at what happened to Giuliani Sydney
Powell I mentioned and others of of uh
Eric I forget the guy's last name all
these different people who have
represented trump it doesn't go well and
he often doesn't pay now we learned that
the Republican National Committee has
been paying some of Trump's legal bills
for a period of time and we talked about
why when we discussed that but it is not
a guarantee that you will even be paid
for your work
um remember the story about one of the
law firms that Trump had representing
him years ago they would always send two
people whenever they had a meeting
because Trump would often lie about what
he said to his own attorneys in previous
meetings so they wanted two people there
so that they could counter the
falsehoods and correct the lies these
were confidential meetings with his own
lawyers and Trump would still lie and of
course as a more General thing in
representing Trump one of the biggest
problems with him as a client is he
can't just shut up
he can't just say nothing and if you
think back to the Russia probe the
Mueller probe whatever you want to call
it if Trump had never said anything and
not attempted to obstruct or tamper with
Witnesses or any of it Trumper just said
I am busy being president I will allow
the investigation to run its course
it would have been over much faster and
Trump would have been under much less uh
legal Jeopardy and so it's hilarious
typically representing a former
president would be a tremendously
prestigious and great thing to do and
lucrative but it seems like representing
Trump is none of those things and
couldn't have happened to a nicer guy
Tucker Carlson is now starting to
prepare his audience for what he
believes is an indictment of Donald
Trump that is coming now there's a
couple different reasons why Tucker
Carlson may be doing this one of the
reasons may be that he is trying to
soften the blow and preemptively sort of
deflate what may be coming so that when
it happens he can say we knew this was
going to happen this is that this is
part of the scam it's part of the Witch
Hunt whatever Tucker Carlson seems to be
pretty friendly with Trump right now you
might remember that a few weeks ago at
this uh excuse me saudi-backed live golf
tournament Liv golf tournament at
Bedminster in I think it's Jersey
uh Tucker Carlson and Marjorie Taylor
green and Trump were photographed
together hanging out so Tucker clearly
has some kind of vested interest in this
and he is now kind of just saying as an
aside the the indictment's coming it's
not even if it's more a matter of when
something to see here
that's the line and no doubt ASA
Hutchinson and Mitch McConnell and Dan
Crenshaw and the rest of them will be
telling you the very same thing when the
Biden justice department
or some other state law enforcement
agency under their influence finally
does what you know they're going to do
which is indict Donald Trump obviously
they're going to do that so the point
here is saying these people are so
biased these people are so in the tank
against Trump they are so viciously
determined to damage him that the
indictment is coming but it's going to
be a bogus indictment it's not going to
be based on anything
who knows how maybe they'll produce
surveillance video from Mar-A-Lago
apparently they've already subpoenaed
that we'll spend the next year talking
about how it shows Trump mishandling
classified information
really on the server remember the
endless Russia collusion hoax we're in
for a lot more of that the endless
Russia collusion hoax which led to 37
indictments and so many people
ultimately pleading guilty that it
recovered more money than it cost to run
that investigation that's the Witch Hunt
Tucker is talking about that's
revisionist history they'll screaming
how Trump is a criminal and if you
express any support for him or any
interest in retaining I don't know the
rights of free speech and due process
you're a criminal too now of course
Trump's rights of free speech have not
been restricted in any way by those
investigating him it is true that he was
banned by Twitter two years ago has
nothing to do with the investigation has
nothing to do with the First Amendment
private company with terms of service
but that the this Trump has been saying
whatever he wants and he can get
interviewed wherever he wants at least
in right wing media anytime he wants and
in terms of due process all the eyes
have been crossed and T's dotted I know
as Sean Hannity said last week in fact
you are the threat you're the threat and
just mention that you disagree with what
is happening is an attack on our
government that's their Style just the
other day after signing off for the
Mar-A-Lago raid your attorney general
mayor Garland came on stage to whine
about how actually he was the victim
here he's the victim apparently some
people disagreed with the raid so the
FBI the most heavily armed domestic law
enforcement agency in the world is now
under threat from you well yes that is
absolutely true there were death threats
to FBI agents uh gunmen showed up at FBI
offices including in Cincinnati Tucker
is completely unhinged and he wants us
to believe that the victim here is Trump
Trump's had his his Free Speech taken
away no he hasn't Trump's had due
process denied no he hasn't and it's
really Trump that is the victim so there
is the view from Tucker Tucker who
recently hung out with Trump at his golf
club he is in a position to give us a
really honest and unbiased assessment uh
now the other thing that I think is
interesting is the right seems to be
talking much more about an indictment
than the left many on the left are sort
of resigned to a possible fate which is
this isn't going to go anywhere in terms
of statements the right continues to say
oh they're going after this guy I was
looking at the conservative subreddit
the other day and they're going on and
on about how there's a secret grand jury
in DC that's imminently going to indict
Trump why are they starting rumors about
their own guy going down is it a sort of
negative visualization and the the style
of the stoic philosophers I don't think
so is it about diffusing the power of
the indictment when it eventually comes
because then it looks more like a plot
rather than actual Justice and due
process maybe or is it all to rile up
the extremists so that some of them
commit the stochastic terrorism that
many of us fear is coming
solely because the possibility of
violence may actually interfere with the
investigation and when there is actual
violence it's probably useful to many of
the people that are supporting Donald
Trump globally to put it lightly I don't
know the answer but you're hearing a lot
more indictment talk from the right than
from the left so there's Tucker's view
if you think Tucker is able to fairly
assess the situation that's his
perspective that an indictment is coming
but it is a bogus indictment we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P here's a voicemail about the
horrifying Salman Rushdie stabbing which
we talked about on yesterday's bonus
show this voicemail is from the Eggman
who we have not heard from from for at
least a few weeks if not a month or two
hey Dave a naked prediction that we will
never see Salman Rushdie in public ever
again either he is passed away or he's
going to say they're going to say he's
dead he's going to fake his own death
that's it we'll never see him again
um I hope he's okay but that's my
prediction Shalom brother yeah um I uh
so since the Eggman left that voicemail
the reports are that Salman rushdie's
condition has improved which is great he
is now I believe if I understand the
last medical report expected to survive
he's 75 years old and despite the fatwa
officially being formally being
rescinded we all knew he was still at
risk does a public appearance and he
gets stabbed it would be perfectly
logical for Salman Rushdie to never show
his face in public again and it's sad
that that's the reality of the situation
but there is a contingent of people
determined determined to see Rushdie
dead and so I mean faking his own death
or simply never appearing in public
again honestly the situation is so crazy
that it all seems somewhat rational if
he were to do something like that for
now let's just continue hoping for his
recovery we have a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about the
complete and total backfire of the
Mehmet Oz crudite video which by the way
I covered months ago months and months
ago it's not a new video but it's gone
viral the Biden Administration has
canceled almost four billion dollars in
student debt for more than 200 000
borrowers we'll tell you who and why and
the NBA the Nash National Basketball
Association has decided it will not hold
games on Election Day in order to
encourage people to vote and of course
right Wingers or Furious even though the
NBA is just saying just go vote we're
not telling you who to vote for all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show get access by signing up at
joinpakman.com